[Music]
what can i help you with lord of
darkness i'm looking for a date the date
is friday july 13th no no i want to meet
someone understood you want to eat dim
sum don't you get it i want to go on a
date i'm
lonely i understand you want bologna
ah too many eyes too few eyes not into
tentacles dad oh maybe you're stressed
out from working too hard you need a
vacation from running everyone else's
vacation and i know just how to fix it
mavis where are we going a crew
surprise
[Music]
try some exotic food
[Music]
or just enjoy the views
okay dad thank you
maybe you'll find your own fireworks on
the cruise it's not the love boat frank
ahoy there
i am captain erica you must be the one
and only dracula
there's something about an accent that
makes a man sound so intelligent
you nailed it honey best summer vacation
ever
you were right great grandfather van
helsing monsters are disgusting
they have no idea what's about to happen
to them
[Music]
there is something about that woman i
don't trust
the food here is to die for
[Music]
must have been garlic in the guacamole
isn't that deadly for you
[Music]
um was that you
uh
[Music]
oh no blobby's gonna puke
[Music]
welcome to the secret headquarters of
the scs stands for small foot exists
suckers
we have searched the entire mountain
trying to find one
and that day has finally arrived
oh
where did it go reach into your memory
it got whisked away on the wind over the
clouds which way up sideways down
[Music]
down of course
he saw a small foot still be out there
and it fell from the sky gary calm down
you know how you get okay i'll try but
i'm just so scared
son it can't be true amigo you will be
banished from the village until you are
ready to tell us the truth i know what i
saw and i'm gonna prove it
is it too late to have second thoughts
yes
if you die can i have all your worldly
possessions
right sorry when you die let's do this
[Music]
oh
stand in here
[Music]
hi
i'm
i'm taking you home
[Music]
[Music]
we're going to be safe here nice and
warm
wait a minute what's
how's that nice and toasty all the way
around
oh hey what's wrong you hungry i found
your food
[Music]
my name is peter parker i'm pretty sure
you know the rest i saved the city fell
in love then i saved the city again and
again and again
look i'm a comic book a cereal i did a
christmas album and a so-so popsicle but
this isn't about me
not anymore
spider-man swings in once a day zip zap
stopping his little mask and answers to
no one i love you moans yeah i know that
you gotta say i love you back dad are
you serious i want to hear you look at
this god i love you
dad
i love you that's a copy
ladies and gentlemen my name is miles
morales
i'm the one and only spider-man
at least that's what i thought you ever
hear for super collider you're gonna
love this
you're like me that's impossible
all right kid listen up this frog is
your universe soggy it's weird it's
gross and this delicious normal fry is
my universe
so you want to learn to be spider-man
can you teach me yes i can time to swing
good you're doing it double tap to
release and whip it out again okay swift
and release your natural thread
hey guys who are you i'm gwen stacy
i'm from another another dimension how
many more spider people are there hey
fellas
hello
this could literally not get any weirder
it can get weirder
okay
we need to get back to our universes
soon brooklyn is going to collapse my
family lives in brooklyn
miles what's wrong
this was never your city
it's mine
if i don't destroy the collider none of
us will have a home to go home too
remember what makes you different let's
go
is what makes you spiderman
officer i love you
wait what
[Music]
that way that way
other way other way other way all the
way
do animals talk in this dimension
because i don't want to freak him out
[Music]
coming this summer
they're finally going to make a movie
about me the story of batman's greatest
ally it's me that must be me and best
friend in the whole world
the movie it's time to clean up this
city
that actually does look pretty
young good with a quick view they're
really making movies about every
superhero has there been a movie about
you there was a green lantern movie but
we don't we don't talk about that it's
time they make one about me i'm afraid
no i only make movies about real
superheroes
why don't they take us seriously titans
you guys are never actually doing
anything heroic what about that time we
discovered that sweet diner and they had
that food
that wasn't even a crime and you didn't
save anything we save room for dessert
having a movie is the only way to be
seen as a real hero what about an arch
nemesis
[Music]
stop right there
deadpool deadpool what why does
everybody think i'm deadpool i thought
deadpool was a good guy by the way he
should be saying that he's not me okay
because i came out like way before he
did nah i'm pretty sure you're dead bull
i am straight
if we can make him our arch nemesis then
they will see that we're worthy of a
movie
i'm not interested in fighting a bunch
of sidekicks and a half a robot
oh man i'm never letting you fly my body
again
the whole world will be under my control
destroy them how big is your army a
hundred thousand oh for the mighty abby
watch me watch me watch me do this it's
always been more than a music
[Music]
with your waffles
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen are you ready to
see the next big thing
let's hear it for the new gen 6.
it's cool you love robots more than you
love me
what's that honey
all children must be accompanied by an
adult you're coming with me young lady
nope
[Music]
hello
maybe we could try and be friends
you're gonna stay here tonight not you
momo i knew that you judging me bro
you being here is like the best thing
that happened to me
why would you put weapons in a robot
something terrible is about to happen
holy mother of toast
7723 is our only hope
[Music]
there's way too much injustice in the
world
together we can fix it
i promise i got your back
[Music]
no
[Music]
he's so cool
[Music]
what do you call him
my friend
[Music]
wow
thank you for opening me oh look out
here i go closing way
[Music]
trampolining
we meet again
superheroes are illegal we want to fight
bad guys
it defines who i am we're not saying you
have
what someone on tv said it
i was approached by this tycoon wants to
talk about hero stuff help me bring
supers back into the sunlight we need
elastigirl bye sweetie
i'll watch the kids no problem
that's not the way you're supposed to do
it dad they want us to do it i don't
know that way why would they change math
math is math math is math all over
duesseldorf doozles are dozing her
eyelids so
[Music]
i couldn't have done this if you hadn't
taken over so well i've got to succeed
so she can succeed
done properly parenting is a heroic act
done properly
[Music]
this is a family-friendly community
you are not family friendly so what's
the problem who's on the loose
i'm giving you one more chance to grow
up show you belong to this flock lead
the junior flies
they're childish do we have to migrate
in a v formation
[Music]
are those your kids sure larry
we got separated from our flock can you
help us or not i would say i'm an or not
[Music]
fine
[Applause]
[Music]
you have no idea what you're doing do
you
how many crazier is your brother
indestructible
three two
[Music]
oh no i'm freaking out hard
if i'm not a racer what am i oh you're
my best friend all we gotta do is find
the part to fix your game everything
goes back to the way it was but where
are we gonna find that the internet
[Music]
want to get rich playing video games
slaughter race he's wicked dangerous
attention to detail is pretty impressive
well well well who are you i think we
should get out of here
show time let's race
come and get it get back on the track
there is no track i can drive
anywhere love it here who knew there's
so many babies and cats in the world
that is what the internet was made for
full of weirdos
i want this to be my life
i don't think i could ever tell ralph
there's no law saying best friends have
to have the same dreams
[Music]
this is what's called the dark net are
you sure this is safe just whatever you
do do not look at his little brother oh
his little brother
what are you doing here
the reason i came to your neck of the
face i mean there's a face in your neck
i mean woods neck of the woods
them wolves are given up it's been a
rough winter they are smart they'll keep
clear at the fire
must be a stray you will never tame that
monster he's got more teeth than brains
we will call you white fang
you must lead this team but they will
not follow you until they respect you
that dog is a killer train them right
and there be no stopping
poor thing he's pretty badly hurt
everything's all right
here
we're not going to hurt you
[Music]
in spite of the gold the greed and the
cruelty
we're trying to build something good and
peaceful up here you will have to make
them see
[Music]
[Music]
the japanese archipelago 20 years in the
future
canine saturation has reached epidemic
proportions
an outbreak of dog flu rips through the
city of nagasaki
mayor kobayashi issues emergency orders
calling for a hasty quarantine trash
island becomes an exiled colony
the isle of dogs
i don't think i can stomach any more of
this garbage
exactly words out of my mouth
nobody's giving up around here and don't
you forget it ever your rex your king
your duke your boss i'm chief we're a
pack of scary indestructible alpha dogs
atari kobayashi you heroically hijacked
a junior turboprop xj750
and flew it to the island because of
your dog
darn it
i've got a crush on you
[Music]
we get the idea you're looking for your
lost dog spots does anybody know it
no no
i have lost all of my pride
spots if he's alive may very well be
living even at this moment as a captive
prisoner
somebody is up to something
will you help him
the little pilot
why should i because he's a 12 year old
boy
dogs love those
we'll find him
wherever he is if he's alive
we'll find your dog
it's gonna be a fight
i wish somebody spoke his language
wow
to the north a long rickety causeway
over noxious sludge marsh leading to a
radioactive landfill polluted by toxic
chemical garbage that's our destination
great get ready to jump
[Music]
merry christmas
[Music]
i'm going to steal their christmas
[Music]
resist
who is this
we will drop the sleigh from the roof
okay
go team
this is the loudest snow i've ever heard
in my life
[Music]
if i'm gonna become santa then i need to
get into character
[Music]
it's go time
your monster
now will be riding in style
[Music]
[Music]
i'm promoting you you will guide my
sleigh tonight
what max
[Music]
yes max
max
you know the rules you sleep in your bed
and i sleep in
max did you teach him puppy eyes
fine
[Music]
oh generous honest
pure graceful creatures our natural
rabbit's pace should be able to keep up
[Applause]
do you know what that would never have
worked
blue checklist no pants you must be
peter rabbit yeah that's right wait
didn't you try to eat me show me your
teeth do like a goat like
it was you i knew it how are you so good
to see you hey
i can't think of one thing that could
stop our fans
[Music]
hello
this way
[Music]
checking on the new neighbor i'll
explain it to him we'll share our land
around here hello i'm b these gates are
incredibly sturdy i just need to keep
the wildlife out where they belong
you're joking right
yes
they're angels this is their place
okay so he's tricked her there's only
one way out of this
he's gotta go
did you know they set traps in my bed
he's a rabbit
he wouldn't hurt anyone
his face was so classic he was like
i have a vermin problem an electric
fence will keep him out
what happens if we touch
we can't give up it's our home
[Music]
my two boys getting along nothing could
make me happier
i got us into this i'm gonna fix it
feel it
[Music]
you